Years ago, when I was doing "One Tree Hill,"
my character was becoming a fashion designer.
So I was like coming to Fashion Week here
and meeting with all these people
and learning about how they do what they do for research.
And I went to this dinner and Rihanna comes to this dinner
and we sit next to each other,
and she's like, "Your show's cool."
We're chatting, I'm dying.
She gives me her phone number,
which I input in my Blackberry at the time.
(audience laughing)
And I never texted her.
And then that photo you showed,
I saw her at an event years later,
and she was like, "How have you been?
I never heard from you."
And I was like, "Oh my God, I ghosted Rihanna."
Like, what is wrong with me?
But I just, I'm like, what do I,
what am I gonna text her?
Like, "Hey girl."
What?
I don't know how to talk to her.
Okay, so I got to spend time
with Oprah Winfrey in Montecito.
No. Oh no.
And she was like,
"I live around the corner, come over.
Let's make soup."
No.
And I, too, was way too intimidated
to be like, "hey."
Like, should we follow through on that, like, plan?
So what if we ask Rihanna and Oprah for a redo?
I would love it.
I would absolutely love it.
Like, social,
scaredy-cat redo.
We'll just show and be like, "Hey ladies,
the awkward girls are here."
Totally!
What's wrong with us?
I'm like, Rihanna's having a baby
and I'm so happy for her.
And I'm like, I can't even tell her congratulations
'cause I never texted her!
Baby clothes.
That's it.
And I'll get Oprah some soup and send it to her.
And we'll right this wrong.